so today I am very excited to have dr.
David Bates with me dr. Bates is the
chief of general medicine at Brigham and
Women's Hospital where he's also the
chief quality officer he has been the
sort of pioneer in studying patient
safety health information technology and
how they intersect quality is important
in healthcare because it's really at the
root of of everything that we do my
first passion is is safety and safety is
the is the first part of quality I got
interested in safety when the results of
the Harvard Medical Practice that he
came out and they showed that lots of
patients were being harmed unnecessarily
I was interested in physician decision
making and it became clear to me that if
we could computerize drug ordering that
we could make a really big dent in
medication safety and medications were
the single leading cause of harm the
reason that I care about safety is is I
think it's awful to harm people with the
care that we deliver and I know that we
can do better around
[Music]